[Música]
fotos pessoal de quem fala andar que
sejam muito bem vindos a mãe ainda mais
um filho pois ao todo saiu e se o merry
christmas deixar que este vírus letal
agenda atenção deixem likes e também
estando nesse vídeo é de 26
o metal precioso é só vai liberar eu não
sei como é conhecido no mundo atual mas
o fax com muita comida muita estratégia
e acontece uma coisa inesperada pessoal
eu recebi que a porta alguma caixa da
concentra o um deus pessoal às vezes
então abrir essa caixa vamos ver o que
tem aqui dentro eu acho que os
brinquedos que dá pra fazer um dos
desafios e com esses desafios vai haver
uma consequência conseqüência esse que
eu não tenho como uns loucos ou anda tão
mal o tamanho da cabeça da grande natal
eu estou tão grande no beisebol é
sociável por ser muito alto mas ao mesmo
tempo a cabeça as festas não é uma opção
[Música]
não uma pessoal gato
eu achei a chuva
o o o que é isso
isso dá choque tomás pergunta como é que
eu carrego ministro usa como se fosse um
punho né ai ai ai ai ai eu não sei se em
casa vocês conseguem perceber o real
barulho deste equipamento electrónico
futurista mas o som muito alto
daí o dem está aí o som não só assim só
assim em vez de bens
ai ai sim ou não abrir as duas
embalagens pet não pode ser só que está
a produzir sob poder que está o da
entanto não encontrou na anterior
[Música]
temos aqui esta cápsula que já tem um
alvo mas pra dar pra fazer do fio acho
que vai dar pra mim não faz em dois
tempos do fim
só sei que não deixarem o lixo vai fazer
uma curva na nossa casa já percebi
brasileiro resta embalagem como é que
este ano ia com um sério mesmo
ganhou ganhou ontem um papel gigante ibm
supostamente é a coleção toda hora eu já
se mandasse deus ai ai ai ai dose de
mais polícias nas ruas onde não só como
podem ver temos um monte mas de bens
muitos que se lançar isto sozinho
[Música]
23 vai a lei ainda já que já ganhava é
que já basta para ganhar não só pela
dimensão do quanto eu sou bonito eu vou
mandar ele tomar gols na competição
olha eu não vamos lá estar a ver se
funciona no ecocentro vocês têm maneiras
de como explorar
estamos lá mas se vocês conseguem fazer
coisas mãe por queijo que vocês
inventaram um chute longe e puxando
demais metas aqui no campeonato e depois
ataca as duas com as regiões palha país
parece um polícia chegou e se brincar
comigo é então a procurar um substituto
só vamos ficar em casa se vocês forem
comprar este brinquedo a algum centro
comercial alguma loja assim quando fui
pagar lá na caixa digão tarde toda a
gente vai saber cuidar foi meu bolso
ídolo
agora sinto muito curioso pra ver aqui é
pista por supostamente estar a fazer
corridas de coisas loucas e aqui nós
vamos fazer o desafio
olha vou lançar mão de mais liquidez
primeira do estado está assim
[Música]
é que está nossa pista pessoa com poder
voltar a funcionar na perfeição olha aí
eu vou colocar aqui o feijão um mate
beans eo vai-não-vai passa pelo martelo
e um veículo button sabe por aqui e nem
tudo é que 10 pelos martelos que
empurram cá para baixo pois passou pelo
sinal e depois trocam que o caminho e
quando chegam aqui há metas 321 bairro
o meu sonho de me estou a ver que você
previu mais pra nós já vamos testar isso
aqui no fim muitas regiões e 1 2 3 4 5 6
9 10 estão em viagem de feijão a isso é
um pequeno vídeo aulas são feijão e isso
é muito louco escrito e que começam toda
acham álbum é uma tarefa não é só dos
jogos aqui
stickers ainda tô
[Música]
meu deus é muita opção para 23
mas não foi só eu estar ou da silva só
eu quem não foi o segredo está no 3 né
militar dois né seu planejamento tudo
uma breve vou deixar agora o fla então o
bom tamanho já conhece mas agora com uma
menina porque também tem uma memória ou
tê las ganho agora é o último a ganhar
ganha isso 321 foi o i am
é mais uma mas o verdão não tanto tem
que cumprir o desafio mais um choque da
explosão não faltou não faz assim data
não não assim
só assim não fui assim caiu dos céus
então tá aí possa não pô não não sai da
prova jogo e alex van não toda ela
entrou na província não está aí
posto isso vai passar
sabe aquela sensação de levar uma
injeção a mesma cena do euro mas foi
muito forte
não não me dói possa estar tipo de
turismo agora tá chato não façam isso em
casa
eu vou embora com uma situação
importante que o da fran é o melhor nos
mais de mim e ela models também que o e
amanhã vamos pegar um metal rock
amanhã eu vou pagar uma entrada faltosa
me a mim
[Música]
olha olha
ae